bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
émission de checkup votre magazine santé
et bien-être ce mois-ci nous allons à la
rencontre de l'association ivelinoise
zigomatique elle approche les enfants
malades de façon étonnante vous
découvrirez cela dans quelques instants
il sera aussi question d'une autre
rencontre celle de Louis et de sa maman
Christine c'est à voisin le Bretonneux
Louis est un jeune adulte autiste depuis
septembre il suit la méthode des trisi
mais tout d'abord le premier sujet la
polémique de cette rentrée la cigarette
électronique est-elle dangereuse oui
pour le mensuel 60 millions de
consommateurs les les usagers eux sont
plus réservés et les professionnels de
la santé partagés
reportage la cigarette électronique
représente-elle un danger pour la santé
dans son numéro de septembre le magazine
60 millions de consommateurs sème le
trouble en révélant que des composés
nocifs potentiellement cancérigène
seraiit contenu dans les vapeurs et
selon le mensuel en quantité non
négligeable comme le formol l'roléine ou
encore le glycole c'est évident que ce
sont pas des produits qui sont chouettes
à inaller et et c'est aussi
ce qu'on demande c'est dans quelle
mesure est-ce qu'on inale ces produits
comment est-ce que ces produits ont été
montrés du doigt alors qu'ils n'ont pas
été montrés par la première étude qui a
été demandée par le gouvernement qui est
quand même une étude officielle et qui
est une étude scientifique bien plus
scientifique que ce que j'ai pu lire
jusqu'à présent sur 60 millions de
consommateurs qui ne donnait absolument
ni chiffr ni protocole dans cette
boutique ouverte en mai dernier qui
compte déjà 3000 clients les utilisateur
tempè noif effectivement là ces derniers
temps onentend parler de ça mais est-ce
que c'est plus nocif que la cigarette en
elle-même je pense pas il y a moins de
produits peut-être dedans nocif donc si
ça peut nous aider dans un premier temps
à tout simplement à passer sans sans le
le goudron enfin t tous les ces produits
et puis après complètement arrêté
pourquoi pas ouais du côté du corps
médical on est partagé pour ce médecin
de toussu le noble il ne faut pas se
tromper de cible il faut je pense
utiliser ce type de de de moyens soit
dans le sRAGE tabagique soit tout
simplement parce qu'il y a des personnes
qui veulent peut-être essayer entre
guillemets de fumer ou de vapoter à ce
moment-là c'est beaucoup moins nocif de
prendre une cigarette électronique que
exactement la la vraie cigarette
classique avec ses 4000 composés donc
plus de 50 on va dire cancérigène
jusqu'à preuve du contraire puisqu'on a
pas d'études saeuses et puis donc on va
dire certifié je pense que exactement la
cigarette électronique reste exactement
un moyen un bon compromis de on va dire
de la cigarette classique
nous sommes à la maison d'Espagne à
Versailles Joë houdda c'est infirmière
spécialisée en tabacologie elle reçoit
des personnes qui veulent arrêter de
fumer imp patient sur TR lui pose la
question sur l'usage ou non de la
cigarette électronique et sa réponse est
sans ambiguïé a priori ça peut devenir
un produit dangereux dans la mesure où
il y a eu des des traces de produits
cancéreux nous on peut pas conseiller le
produit dans la mesure où il y a pas eu
donc d'études faites et d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché ce produit n'est
pas du tout anodin comme ça avait été
annoncé par ses fabricants actuellement
la cigarette électronique séduit plus
d'un million de personnes en
France l'association ivelinoise
zigomatique a été créée en 1999 elle
intervient dans le domaine de la santé
tous ces adhérents sont bénévoles ils se
grimment en clou clown et vont à la
rencontre des enfants malades
l'association recherche d'ailleurs des
bénévoles rencontre avec MAE changeur
clown et
bénévole bonjour mot de changeur vous
êtes secrétaire adjoint de l'association
zigomatique qui a été créée en 1999
c'est une association qui intervient
dans dans les iblines et le but ce sont
des clown qui vont à la rencontre des
enfants malades dans les dans les
hôpitaux alors d'abord pourquoi des
clown c'est important euh oui c'est
important parce que grâce au clown on
rentre plus facilement en contact avec
le costume le nez ça crée un lien direct
avec les enfants les parents les
soignants enfin on est repéré tout de
suite quoi en fait mais on se dit malgré
tout que ça doit pas être simple enfin
comme ça vu de l'extérieur d'aller à la
rencontre d'enfants qui sont malades
alors comment on travaille entre
guillemets ou comment on se prépare en
tout cas pour aborder ses enfants bah
déjà je pense que il faut faire
ressortir son âme d'enfant donc je pense
que ça tout le monde tout le monde l'a
en soi après faut savoir lâcher prise et
puis le fait d'avoir le costume le nez
ça permet de de pouvoir faire toutes les
folies possibles inimaginables c'est
quoi les folies ah bah c'est que malgré
tout ça reste dans un cadre médical avec
des enfants qui peuvent avoir des
pathologie ah bah c'est-à-dire partir
dans un monde complètement fou ne
serait-ce qu'à partir d'un tout petit
objet qu'on aura trouvé qu'à partir à
l'enfant ou des des choses faut faut
faut laisser partir son imagination quoi
et puis emmener l'enfant avec nous je
mets des oreilles de cochon donc voilà
dou piglette après il y a le
je vais mettre juste du coup parce que
voilà par exemple chez les tout petits
ça va être plus des chansons avec des
bulles enfin des des choses plus
visuelles et plus auditives après avec
les plus grands ça peut
être des des sculptures de
ballon ça peut être partir dans une
histoire folle avec leur doudou ou avec
leur pap ou leur maman alors ça ils
adorent quand on arrive on on demande
juste s'il y a des consignes
particulières par exemple porter le
masque dans la chambres des choses comme
ça est-ce qu'il y a des chambres à faire
avant les autres mais sinon on pose
aucune question sur les maladies parce
que ça rentre pas du tout en compte dans
le jeu du clown en fait ça c'est pas du
tout pris pris en compte j'ai d
l'association existe depuis 1999 elle
intervien dans nombreux hôpitaux
notamment dans dans les ivelines et vous
recherchez des bénévoles et oui c'est
vrai plus on est de clown plus on rit
hein c'est le vieil adâ c'est bien oui
donc il Fautre beaucoup de clown c'est
ça mais en fait ça permet de de de
tourner à plusieurs et puis de de faire
vivre l'association en fait le seul
critère c'est d'avoir plus de enfin
d'avoir 18 ans et plus je demandé s'il y
a un profil particulier benah voilà
c'est 18 ans ou plus et avoir envie de
donner euh de partager des
choses avoir son âme d'enfant donc comme
je disais et puis après
s'engager pour un certain nombre de
visites pour l'année puis adhérer à
l'association c'est combien le nombre de
visite le nombre de visite c'est 5
minimum par an d'accord il y a pas du
tout besoin d'avoir un parcours
particulier mais par contre il a il y a
une
formation qui est faite donc tous les
mois on se retrouve à Chatou à la maison
de l'au viive et et en fait on fait des
exercices d'improvisation
des des mises en situation alors vous
êtes clown depuis un an et demi dans
l'association qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie de de passer le pas alors en fait
à la base je voulais faire du bénévola
et puis en recherchant sur internet je
suis tombée sur cette association et
étant moi-même infirmière ayant pu
bénéficier du travail de de
clown je savais qu'on enfin que c'était
super important et pour les soignants
les parents et les enfants pendant qu'on
s'habille et tout voilà ou là là
j'espère que ça va aller et puis après B
on s'y jette et comme on a le nez le
costume et tout on est quelqu'un d'autre
donc voilà quoi c'est ça se fait
vraiment tout seul et à votre avis ça
vous a apporté quoi ou ça vous apporte
quoi euh c'est quand on fait du bénévolà
c'est pour les autres mais c'est aussi
un peu pour soi oui ah bah oui bah c'est
c'est un moment de partage d'échange de
enfin on est content quand quand un
enfant nous renvoie plein de sourirees
les parents aussi quand on se met à
danser dans les couloirs avec les so on
se dit bah on apporte un peu de gêé dans
dans leur quotidien du changement quoi
je dis pas qu'il y a pas de moment de
gué non plus sans nous mais ça fait ça
leur apporte une petite lumière en plus
quoi ouais la petite lumière en plus
c'est joli oui c'est ça c'est joli comme
phrase je vais aussi finir par la phrase
d'un psychiatre allemand qui dit le
clown détient la clé pour ouvrir l'âme
de l'enfant voilà c'est ça donc c'est
que voilà ça résume ce que vous n avez
VO l'âme d'enfant bah du clown enfin de
celui qui fait le clown et puis bah des
parents des soignants et des enfants
euxmême enfin qui
déjà spontanément mais voilà quoi
c'estok merci beaucoup
merci Christine Vincent géau est la mère
de Louis un jeune adulte autiste depuis
un an elle a adopté une nouvelle
pratique d'aide au développement la
méthode des troisi intensif interactif
individuel la famille vcinoise recherche
elle aussi des bénévoles pour l'aider
dans des séances quotidiennes nous la
vont rencontrer chez
elle Louis est un jeune adulte autiste à
raison de quatre séances d'une heure et
demi chacune il suit une méthode de
développement peu connue la méthode 3i
3i comme intensif individuel interactif
ça se passe dans une salle de jeu qui
est aménagé selon la méthode
c'est-à-dire que il y a une balancelle
qui permet à l'enfant ou au jeunes de se
balancer de se détendre ce qui est très
important dans cette méthode et aussi ça
permet au bénévoles d'être juste en face
de l'enfant ou du jeune parce qu'on ce
qu'on recherche bien sûr c'est le
contact des yeux mais l'échange et en
fait c'est comme ça qu'on commence à
créer la relation ce qui est
primordial Francis est bénévole depuis
le mois de septembre il vient 3 jours
par semaine pour accompagner Louis dans
son développement c'est vraiment un
partage
et ce que j'essaie de faire avec mon ami
Louis c'est être vraiment à l'écoute
mais vraiment une écoute active essayer
à chaque fois à partir d'une de ces
attitudes d'enchaîner un jeu dans lequel
il va devenir acteur au début je
m'amusais à prendre sa main quand il
donne tu me donnes ta main Louison voilà
il me donn la main et puis après je dit
ouvre ta main louon et on va jouer
d'accord tu l'attrapes mon doigt et
c'est pas parce qu'ils sont là il faut
le faire e oh ah tu as manqué oh bravo
bon voilà c'est ce petit jeux qu'on
qu'on s'est amusait à faire et puis
après il devient vraiment acteur temps
en temps c'est lui qui me tend la main
pour que je puisse mettre mon doigt et
qu'on puisse l'attraper voilà c'est cet
échange là c'est là où je dis qu'il faut
une écoute actique est-ce que tu veux
faire un sour ou alors là sur command
c'est pas évident oh ça va re difficile
oh non hein tu peux pas sourrir oh non
juste une grimace ou B non euh il s'est
redressé il a un meilleur regard même si
à notre avis il avait déjà un bon regard
mais il a un bien meilleur regard il il
regarde maintenant les animaux
l'escalier par exemple il montait il
descendait déjà tout seul bien sûr mais
il descend beaucoup mieux il prend
beaucoup plus de risque avec son cors
qu'avant c'est une méthode qui n'est
développée en France que depuis 7 ans
Christine lance un appel au bénévoles il
faut juste j'allais dire être ouvert
d'esprit bien sûr mais savoir jouer avec
un enfant il y a aucune connaissance
médicale paramédicale à
avoir actuellement une quinzaine de
personnes se relaent tous les jours du
lundi au dimanche idéalement la famille
recherche une dizaine de personnes qui
pourraient consacrer 1 heure et dem par
semaine à leur fils Louis une formation
et bien endu
proposer ce nouveau numéro de checkup
touche à sa fin avant de nous quitter
nous allons jeter un petit coup d'œil
sur l'agenda et sur ce qu'il faut
retenir le 21 septembre c'est la journée
mondiale de la lutte contre Alzheimer la
veille le groupe gérondicap propose
toute une après-midi sur cette
thématique réservée au personnel
soignant et aux familles des malades
vous serez tout sur les dispositifs
d'aide l'accompagnement à domicile ou
encore sur les équipes spécialisées
Alzheimer sur le secteur checkup c'est
terminé merci de votre attention je vous
donne rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez-vous
bien